voici la colline à la villa
olé
honnêtement
si la colonne des nappes filao mais il
en a aussi une multitude d'espèces
d'arbres d'ici ou venus d'ailleurs c'est
justement ce regard particulier que
porte les réunionnais sur leurs rares
que l'office national des forêts a voulu
valoriser en mettant en place pour la
deuxième année consécutive son concours
auprès de mon arbre ça va être une photo
un des simples avec un petit texte pour
expliquer quelles sont ses émotions des
souvenirs les espoirs parfois des
malheurs et il faut rebondir l'arbre
c'est la ville ancrée sérieux de
passagers ça le d'émotion des
récompenses pour plus de 200 personnes
mais au total plus de 400 participants
preuve que chaque pic bois n'est
l'histoire et sur tous ces amoureux
c'est le cas d'hier aîné d'adam qui ont
obtenu le prix spécial du jury pour un
arbre qui raconte l'histoire de la
réunion et qui est également le symbole
de leur amitié
c'est dans l'époque des esclaves à cette
personne et puis là mais les rangs le
mal de sa mémoire parfois par cette
langue vit toujours
l'histoire de cette table les près de
chez nous à la convenance parce que
c'est là qu'est ma que je vais les
boucler mon enfance j'ai table et je
vais bien comme ça à l'école et des
passes devant litres le temps et les tic
toujours cette étude appareils alors
qu'il a voulu enfin comptez bien
renommage déjà arabe et aussi en même
temps à la mémoire et comme mon dieu ça
redonne un autre vie ah là là parce que
différent des gens il peut donc ça et à
moins quand il ya apparemment le
concours tout et voilà c'est la
meilleure occasion de mettre talents
réunis
auprès de mon arbre je vivais heureux
j'aurais jamais dû m'éloigner de mon
arbre près de son arbre comme le
chantait georges croissance c'est la
vision de marie-andrée qui vit au
chaudron et son arbre et pour elle le
symbole de l'amour des photos des
peintures des dessins qui devaient tous
être accompagnées d'un texte qui
décrivait la relation particulière
qu'entretient l'auteur et cet arbre
qu'il a choisi de faire concourir
plusieurs catégories dont celle des
scolaires et là les petits et les grands
au chacun à leur manière livres et des
mots ou encore des photos et signalement
avec reg et que ce soit là qu'un en
question on a travaillé sur un dessin on
n'est pas aussi dessiné un homme mais on
a fait la peinture la couleur et ensuite
on a envoyé pour le concours des faits
représenter le collège et l'arbre qu'on
aimait bien et promet fait ce choix
d'arbres alors en fait tenable plus
liquide et le collège c'est celui qu on
l a vu gros investisseurs un concours
mené en partenariat avec le quotidien le
rectorat et le nf le wef qui gère 168
milles hectares de bois de forêts des
espaces naturels dont 98% appartient au
département de l'arrêt
ah ben je vivais heureux j'aurais jamais
dû le quitter des yeux